hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear so we got a real interesting one
for you guys today ever since uh he kind
of came to the attention i guess
bursting onto the world stage or
something like that with his very
surrealistic and quite awesome actually
debut movie pie back in 1997
the director darren aronofsky
has been seen as kind of a provocative
filmmaker i guess maybe not usually like
controversial in the way that you know
maybe some other ones are but
definitely provocative so he always gets
like that kind of label attached to him
but despite that i actually don't really
remember any of his movies
drawing the
same kind of controversy and in some
cases even like very very passionate
hatred
that his 2017 movie mother did
now i remember
hearing kind of wildly
divisive opinions about this you know in
the years since it came out
but i only just got around to watching
i've been wanting to see it for a really
long time because i really liked aaron
aronofsky's movies generally but i just
you know didn't get around to it for
whatever reason now happily that whole
entire time you know like the four or so
years that it's been since it came out i
was actually able to avoid any spoilers
and really i didn't have much of an
inkling what the movie was about until i
sat down to watch it i'm sure i've
mentioned on this before probably
multiple times that i really like to go
into movies and books knowing as little
as possible about them because i like to
kind of come at them with a completely
fresh perspective i don't like to have
any sort of like opinions or any you
know i just don't like to know anything
about stuff like before i see it
with this movie though i'm not sure
i'm not sure if that would be the best
approach for everybody i mean i'm glad
that i watched it like without knowing
what it was like going into it but i
don't know if everyone's going to have
that same experience i think it's going
to kind of be up to the individual
whether
you want to know what you're in for
going into it
i mean because i feel like maybe some
people might find the story more
impactful and maybe less bewildering uh
if they know ahead of time kind of like
what the i'm going to say the
allegorical framework of what they're
looking at is um but then again other
people might kind of want to discover
that for themselves as they're watching
it
but i mean however you choose to
approach this movie uh i definitely feel
that uh you know despite the rather
bizarre animosity that it received not
just from audiences either i wasn't like
shocked when audiences like when a lot
of people in the audiences didn't like
it but even from critics i mean there
were some critics that thought it was
like the greatest thing since sliced
bread but a lot of critics really really
seem to hate it and i don't really get
that but okay but this is still a movie
that i thought was brilliant and i'm
going to be thinking about this thing
like years from now i guarantee it so
whether you agree with me that it's uh
you know a kind of a multi-layered
masterpiece or whether you just despised
it for whatever reason because you
thought it was pretentious twaddle or
whatever the hell the reason was uh
there's absolutely no denying that
mother
got people talking and obviously stirred
up some pretty intense emotions so
that's kind of what great art is
supposed to do so you have to at least
give it that
now keep in mind that to talk about this
movie in any meaningful way whatsoever
i'm gonna need to get into some stuff
that happens in the story and talk about
some of the symbolism and stuff like
that um you know just to kind of like
put it in context make it make sense so
if you would like to be one of those
people that comes to mother completely
blind which like i said i'm not sure
if if that's the best way to go about it
because it's like on an individual thing
i'm glad that i went into it like that
but i can see how some people might not
uh they might want to kind of be
pre-warned of what's gonna happen but so
i'm gonna spoil a bunch of stuff uh
pretty much all of it so
if you wanna see it without any
preconceptions or anything like that
then you might want to circle back to
this review later on after you've
actually seen it so we can actually kind
of have more of an in-depth discussion
without worrying about spoiling it for
people now in my view and again this is
all just my opinion maybe people don't
agree with me i think
that mother can absolutely be
appreciated simply on its surface level
as let's call it a really nightmarish
psychological horror film like the first
two thirds of it is almost a little bit
like rosemary's baby like not exactly i
don't want to like oversell that too
much but it has like the same kind of
vibe and the same kind of like paranoia
type thing as rosemary's baby so you can
appreciate on that level and then like
it just kind of gets more insane more
grotesque more inscrutable like as the
story unfolds so you can completely
appreciate it on that level even though
like i said it is surrealistic and
unless you kind of know what the
framework is you'll just
i don't know it'll maybe kind of seem
like shit's just happening randomly
but you i think you can still appreciate
it just as a straightforward horror
movie just albeit one that has like a
very very strange narrative
but i'm gonna say that if you're sort of
tuned in to all the overlapping
allegories and all of the things that
all the characters represent um which to
be honest when you're watching that
movie watching the movie i don't think
it's all that subtle like the allegories
um it's not that difficult to figure out
like what the characters are supposed to
represent which is actually one of the
criticisms that it got like from some of
the critics that the [ __ ] was too
obvious that didn't really bother me but
whatever but if you get that like it's a
lot more it gives the movie a lot more
resonance and like a much larger scope
at least in my opinion again so at the
beginning of the movie uh we see a woman
played by jennifer lawrence who is never
named but is referred to in the credits
and also on the closed captioning
because my deaf ass always has closed
captioning on uh she's called mother
so she's married to a much older man
played by javier bardem
and he's only referred to as him
now the couple apparently lives in just
isolated bliss in this lovely victorian
mansion
that mother has been pretty much
single-handedly restoring after the
house was destroyed by a fire at some
point in the past so we don't know how
long it's been
so mother is portrayed as a very giving
woman uh she loves her husband so much
that she basically just like works
tirelessly around the clock to return
his house to its former glory like i
said after it all burned up
she also takes care of all the household
chores cooking cleaning laundry all that
kind of stuff without you know really
complaining while him who it is
established is a poet who's been
suffering from writer's block for a
while he just kind of like wanders
around the halls wanders around outside
sits in his office and kind of like
struggles to come up with a new artistic
creation that maybe will restore him to
his former glory bring him the adulation
that he kind of like feels he deserves
one important object
in the movie which is established very
early on
is this vaguely heart-shaped crystal
now him keeps this on a stand in his
office and he appears to value this
crystal very very highly he explains a
bit later on that this crystal was the
only thing that survived this
devastating blaze that destroyed his
entire past home and everything in it
there are a couple of other kind of odd
things happening as well
such as
mother has like occasionally she seems
like she's not feeling very well so like
she kind of like gets sort of dizzy and
like kind of grabs at her midsection and
stuff like that like she's sick and then
she goes in the bathroom and takes this
kind of medicine which is like in an old
fashiony looking bottle and it's like
this yellow powder and it sort of looks
like sulfur and like she puts it in
water and so and then like drinks it um
so there's that and then a few times too
like while she's working on the house
she actually like presses her hands up
against the plaster and we see what
looks like kind of like a pulsing like
living heart behind the walls of the
house but other than those few like
little weird things going on mother and
him seem to be living a very quiet very
idyllic existence out here in this
remote mansion now into this tranquil
setting
disruption soon appears in the form of
ed harris don't you hate when ed harris
just turns up and disrupts turns your
life upside down
ed harris's character is known only as
man
now at first he claims to be a doctor
and he says oh i came to this house
because somebody in town or whatever
told me it was a bed and breakfast and i
need a place to stay
now mother is very wary of this stranger
who is just like turned up and invaded
their sanctuary and
a lot of the stuff i mean she's trying
to be polite and stuff but as it goes on
like he seems like a little bit of a
clod like
you know smoking when she expressly told
him not to like he's kind of like going
i don't know he's trying to like taking
like a lot of liberties like going in
rooms like after she tells him not to
she like leaves them like leaves a mess
like that she has to clean up [ __ ] like
that
so she's really not happy about this
whole situation
but because him and man seem to kind of
like hit it off right away and start
browing out him invites man to stay so
mother just kind of tries to suck it up
and you know she's like well i guess i
gotta make the best of it because him
wants him around and they won't really
listen to me that i don't like it so you
know what i mean i mean how bad could
this all turn out after all so that
night man evidently drinks too much and
mother gets woken up by the sound of him
like wretching or like throwing up so
him is in the bathroom and man is
helping him out like while he's you know
crouching over the porcelain throne or
whatever and when mother goes to see
goes to the bathroom to see if man is
okay she briefly sees like this horrible
like bloody wound on man's side which
him like just covers up real quick
the next morning though man seems
completely okay says he feels wonderful
whatever
but if mother thought having man around
was an imposition
then she has another thing coming
because michelle pfeiffer as woman
then turns up on the doorstep that
morning and she is an even bigger pain
in the ass than man was she's very
condescending she's very nosy very
impertinent like asking really
impertinent questions like going places
she's not supposed to go generally she
walks around like she owns the place and
she's just very very i mean just she you
you can tell like she obviously like
thinks mother is like a piece of [ __ ]
and she's like always like talking down
to her and [ __ ] like that now because
woman is such a [ __ ] [ __ ] like
mother tries to put her foot down but
nobody is listening to her and they all
just do what they want like she's just
kind of going hey can you not do that
hey can you not go in there haken and
they're just like whatevs like they
don't even like give a [ __ ] what she's
talking about him doesn't want to make
man and woman leave because he finds out
that man actually isn't a doctor he lied
about that but is actually a super fan
of hims books
uh who is also dying and his dying wish
was to come and meet
uh him and hang out with him like before
he died
so him is actually overjoyed to have
someone around who is just so enamored
of his work and so it ends up that his
ego essentially like overrides anything
that his wife might want because like
obviously she doesn't know these people
and they're kind of jerks and she
doesn't really want them like up in her
house she wanted it just be it her and
her husband and them restoring their
house like happy like they were before
however man and woman take things a
little bit too far at one point they go
into him's office which mother actually
strictly forbade them from doing and
they break him's prized crystal
him flips the [ __ ] out and kicks them
out and boards up his office and mother
actually at this point she's like shoot
i'm finally rid of these intrusive
creeps but him quite bafflingly allows
them to stay in the house over mother's
obviously unheated objections now
shortly after this man and woman's two
adult sons also show up unexpectedly the
place is getting to be like [ __ ]
grand central station up in here when
before it was just like this people
isolated house or whatever
one of the sons is apparently pissed
that man's will favors one son over the
other
and then this big brawl ensues like in
the house like they're breaking [ __ ] all
over like without caring about it and uh
ends up one brother murders the other
one like he knocks his head in with like
a broken doorknob or something like that
and this leaves a blood stain on the
floor that mother can never remove like
for the rest of the movie
now after this happens like after the
sun dies and you know they're all grief
stricken about it and all that [ __ ] man
and woman's whole extended family and
circle of friends and all these other
people invade the house pretty much like
seems like in the middle of the night
because you know mother and him are
woken up by it and they have kind of
like an impromptu wake
and
him gets all into it he's like yeah i'll
say some words about even though he
didn't even know the kid and all this
other kind of [ __ ] and so all these
people just come in they're just like
walking in and like bringing food and
all these other good booze and
everything and mother's like standing
there in her pajamas in a row like what
the [ __ ] like just this is my house what
the [ __ ] and they're all just like
coming in and she's trying to be nice
and trying to accommodate them but still
she's like completely bewildered like
who the [ __ ] are all these people what
are they doing in here why are they
acting like this is their house and it's
just all this other kind of stuff so
basically she's
doesn't really know what to do and all
the guests are basically treating her
like garbage and acting as though she's
being the unreasonable one when she asks
them hey please don't trash the place
hey stop poking around in our bedroom
hey quit going through our [ __ ] you know
what i mean because they're absolutely
doing that and then looking at her like
what you know what i mean so it's that
kind of thing so this part i mean this
part of the movie was like very very
exciting and too sick for me because i
could like imagine what that would be
like it was like i was like oh my god
that'd be [ __ ] horrifying now during
the party uh a pipe breaks after because
she told a couple of the [ __ ] hey i
haven't braced that sink yet because
like i said she's still renovating the
house so please don't sit on it but they
keep sitting on it anyway she's like i
told you please don't sit on that you
know it's it's not safe for like for you
to sit on but they keep doing it anyway
and then just to be dicks they like
start jumping up and down on it and
obviously breaks breaks a pipe it does
water sprays everywhere essentially like
kind of floods the kitchen out and so
everyone finally leaves
now even though the guests obviously
left this giant mess for mothers to
clean up
she's finally she's relieved to kind of
like finally have her peaceful existence
back or so she thinks now what happens a
little bit after this is that she and
him
actually have sex after what is implied
to be a very very long time
and then the next morning she
immediately knows that she's pregnant
now inspired by this pregnancy and as
well as all of the love and appreciation
of all the people that had overrun their
house and were like acting like he was
god's gift he ends up writing his magnum
opus this book which gets published to
the sort of fawning accolades of fans
worldwide
now these fans start showing up at the
house in mass when mother is almost
ready to give birth and
what began as a little bit of an
unsettling bit of kind of like hero
worship it's like you know it's like
just a little not a little contingent of
people like on the porch oh can i have
your autograph this book means so much
to me blah blah and all this other stuff
eventually like the crowds get bigger
and bigger and bigger and as it goes on
like the third act of this movie is like
batshit insane like it just escalates
into sheer
insanity more and more people start
descending on the house they start
destroying everything and like just
ripping [ __ ] off the wall i want to
prove that i was here i wanted something
from this house and they keep like they
like taking it apart going all over the
place as it goes on they start like
setting up shrines to the writer and it
just kind of like and then they start
killing one another over differing
opinions about the book and then they
start beating and abusing mother who at
this point is like still like she's real
pregnant she's like ready to pop
and after she gives birth him basically
she's like i'm not giving you guys the
baby because i don't trust this [ __ ]
[ __ ] so she's like locked in a room but
him wants to show the baby to like all
of his followers and so he goes out
there and inevitably uh the baby they
take the baby and uh kill it and eat it
so you know so there's that um just and
all the while like him is just kind of
sitting back and allowing all of it to
happen i mean he's kind of like upset
about it oh i'm sorry i'm sorry like to
mother and everything like that but he
doesn't really seem as upset about it as
you think at this point uh
understandably mother has had enough and
she just burns the whole thing down and
at that point like toward the end of the
movie like him pulls out the heart like
she's still alive but she's all like
charred and stuff and he pulls the heart
out of her charred body um you know do
you still have any love left to give me
and she's like i have nothing left to
give you but admits that she still does
love him a little bit uh so he pulls her
heart out it crumbles and then there's
another crystal uh you know in the
middle of the heart and then that causes
the whole cycle to begin again with a
new mother like a new woman a different
actress now as if my breakdown of the
plot didn't make it abundantly clear
the entirety of mother is kind of like
an environmental apocalypse story
couched in the framework of biblical
allegory which is i think why uh mother
would actually make an excellent double
feature with aronofsky's other kind of
biblical freakout uh noah from 2014
which actually i thought was quite a
great film
so him uh javier bardem's character is
actually the creator god
obviously mother is mother earth or
mother nature uh the house is actually
like a microcosm of the planet and also
an extension of mother so at the
beginning of the story um a new cycle of
creation has begun because mother like
wakes up in the bed and him and mother
are essentially like in the garden of
eden or before like the creation of
humanity but then uh man and woman who
are adam and eve the wound in man's side
should have made this like pretty
obvious as it's a reference to adam's
rib being used to create eve
they show up and even though they're
disrespectful of mother's wishes him
keeps them around because he needs their
adulation that's why he created them
after all uh after they break hims
crystal which is symbolic of the fruit
of the tree of knowledge him banishes
him from the office but not from the
overall house so like out from the
garden but not from the earth you know
what i mean
so then the suns arrive who are
obviously representing cain and abel
one kills the other uh leaving a blood
stain on the floor which i think like
represents like original sin or like
knowledge of violence or whatever the
pipe bursting at the party uh was kind
of like the flood writ small um and that
got all the people out of the out of the
house for a time like a reset um but
then like after the whole rebirth and
everything like that with her getting
pregnant and him writing the book then
all the humanity all the people come
back with a vengeance and they just
start trashing the plays like
slaughtering one another and acting like
they have every right to do so while him
who like i said is the creator god
continues to forgive them because he's
unable to create without the worship of
humanity that's why he creates humans so
they can worship him
then mother gives birth to her baby who
is obviously jesus uh and he gets
murdered and devoured by hymns ardent
followers and then mother finally erupts
with kind of like righteous anger and
wipes the whole slate clean again him
creates the world anew but all the
people from the last iteration are dead
and it's implied that this cycle will
endlessly repeat itself like with god
trying he's like oh well back to the
drawing board gonna try it again with
that one but because he creates humans
every single time as flawed because he
only wants them for their worship then
it's inevitably gonna end up the same
every single way because humans are
imperfect and are kind of dicks so not
only is mother actually kind of like a
pretty succinct encapsulation of the old
and new testaments it's also a pretty
cynical i guess examination of how
humans have very short-sightedly like
[ __ ] up the environment they live in
also an interesting condemnation this
might have been why some christian
audiences didn't really like it uh
because it's kind of like an interesting
condemnation of the creator god who is
actually portrayed in this movie as
essentially a selfish and emotionally
distant husband who never listens to his
wife and doesn't really care all that
much about her concerns
he only really gives a [ __ ] about his
own creations like these horrible humans
um you know that he's taking their side
like over hers essentially and because
that's all he cares about he just cares
about these human creations and the
deification that they bestow on him on a
smaller scale too um you can kind of
read this in a in a different way i
don't even think it's a different way
it's just kind of like another layer of
the onion i guess but on a smaller scale
it also kind of alludes to any kind of
artist or creator who ends up taking
sort of like the heart and soul of their
muse maybe and using that to create art
but at the expense of the muse who has
given everything to them but really
receives nothing in return i've also
seen a few people point out that the
first two thirds of the movie is a
fairly good reenactment of what it's
like being in a relationship with a
narcissist which like i said that's yeah
i can totally see that and that totally
tracks like with the whole creator god
because that's kind of like the
character that they're portraying him as
they're portraying him as a selfish god
that's he doesn't really care about the
earth he doesn't really care about
anything like that he just cares about
having these little acolytes he creates
them and you know they'll so he cares
about his creation and the worship that
they give him and that's all that he
cares about so this was a very intense
very messed up movie for sure
and it obviously will not be for
everyone especially considering that a
newborn infant gets torn apart and eaten
toward the end so you know that's going
to turn off some people obviously
it's very bold it's very audacious it's
uh kind of challenging and although in
my opinion uh the symbolism is pretty
readily apparent i think um that even if
you're coming at it like without the
same sort of judeo-christian context and
like knowing the biblical allegory and
stuff i think you can still appreciate
it because it's still it's like a crazy
like wild ride i mean honestly and i
think i alluded to this earlier but it's
like the anxiety that i felt watching it
wasn't even so much from all the
biblical stuff um it was just thinking
about like what a nightmare it would be
to have all these random [ __ ] like
wandering into your house acting like
they could do what they want that they
own the [ __ ] even though you keep
telling them to knock it off and then
having like your supposedly
loving partner just let it happen and
like essentially just ignoring you while
you're just like hey can you not do that
hey can you what what no they're awesome
they can stay they can trash the whole
place and then you come out of the day
like they just trash the whole kitchen
and left dishes and [ __ ] everywhere and
then you're just like i'm gonna clean
this up now jesus christ but yeah so i
could so i could kind of like relate to
it on that way like it was very anxiety
inducing so i mean
but the bigger issue of these random
[ __ ] like invading the house being
indicative of the whole of humanity and
your house being the earth that they're
just like basically [ __ ] all over um
that was just kind of the icing on the
macrocosmic cake i guess but i think you
can enjoy this on a lot of different
levels is what i'm saying so love it or
hate it i mean you have to admit that
mother almost kind of like dares you to
have an opinion about it one way or the
other and i'm always going to respect a
filmmaker like darren aronofsky who very
deliberately tries to shake moviegoers
complacency i guess by showing them
something that is almost guaranteed to
like push people's buttons i mean i
added i loved this movie and while i can
understand that people didn't care for
it because they thought it was
pretentious or offensive or for whatever
reason um for me i found it like a
really psychologically it was very
psychologically exhausting but
ultimately i found it
uh quite a rewarding experience and i'm
sure i will probably give it a second
watch to pick up some more symbolism and
stuff that i missed the first time
around because this is definitely one of
those movies that you want to see and
the way that it's structured too is like
a loop it's like uh you know it's like
cyclical so if you watch it again it'll
be like an endless like repeating loop
and so i think that's a good argument
for like watching it again so
if you've seen mother let me know what
you thought about in the comments did
you love it did you hate it uh do you
generally like darren aronofsky's films
or do you think he's pretentious or
whatever let's have a discussion about
it in the comments and that will do it
for this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one
bye